thank you
hey what's going on you guys it's a
little bit dark in here yeah how's this
lighting what the [__] happened I don't
know
I was I haven't been here all day what
are you asking me for you know what it
is put the light in on the little camera
isn't on well that wasn't it wasn't on
before last time no
well you told me to darken the camera
because before you told me it was too
bright yeah this is this shit's [__]
up well you know every time like I said
I didn't change anything but you know
I don't know what to tell you
I don't know what to tell you and I even
like brighten this [__] up or yeah let
me hold on hold on hold on
get one click there I mean that's too
like I think that's too bright but
whatever
yeah darken that
oh well I just write it because I didn't
know you're doing that I brightened the
other ones
that's good
I just brought in these okay I may have
I may have uh dimmed these after the
show yeah maybe you did I do because
like I said I haven't been in here and I
haven't touched anything so you know I
think I dimmed them yeah so you know
whatever
where'd Pookie go you've had her for
like two seconds and then she took it
out there in the bathroom oh okay yeah
she's farting around all right so uh hey
you guys it's Monday and uh we're doing
a movie review so just as I promised we
went over the weekend on Saturday
afternoon and finally saw the last
Voyage of the demeanor which I had
actually been
looking forward to for quite a long time
there was a lot of people in the theater
actually I mean considering
um that it was like a horror movie and
like a literary horror movie yeah so
there was more people in there than I
was thinking because I I heard it's not
doing very well because I mean I think
Barbie and Oppenheimer are still like
kicking everyone's ass so this movie
didn't really make all that much money
like in its opening weekend and the
reviews it seems have been kind of mixed
which is kind of strange I really liked
it too I thought it was great yeah I
thought it was great
it's a universal monster they keep
trying to reboot the universal monster
things and I don't know if it's possible
in the modern era to do it with such old
stories
that have to be they're gold Gothic
horror stories and they have to be told
period
and a lot of people don't want to see a
period movie
this is great I thought it was great man
uh
if you've ever read the book Dracula you
know it does mention what happens on the
ship that Dracula took from
his homeland to to England
and this shows what happens on that ship
and the guys that were on involved with
it it's a lot like the thing
or alien or alien like the guy that
wrote the original spec script he said
he was basically he's he was adapting
that chapter of the novel but he also
kind of wanted to make it like alien
except honestly yeah and they uh they
didn't know what it was there was
attacking them they couldn't believe
that it was a vampire towards the end
and the main character is a guy who
almost didn't get taken didn't get
selected for the voyage
he's a black British guy who just
um got out of University what was it
Cambridge Cambridge yeah and he was kind
of overqualified for the ship they're
like they were looking at his hands
saying are you too soft you know we need
like real men on this [__] he's a doctor
though he's a doctor and he goes how are
you going to help us and he goes I see
and he's like you know well I know all
about astronomy you know if you get lost
I can do it just by the Stars they said
no
but then later on
um he ended up saving a little boy from
getting crushed by a crate and they saw
that happen they liked him so then
um and then one of the crewmen decided
he wasn't going to go when he saw that
damn Dracula's casket or Dracula's boxes
being like the drag on the ship so yeah
it's called the signal of Draco or
dracul you know
and feel like and he was like oh hell no
[__] that [__] he was Romanian he knew
all about that as I'm not getting on
this ship y'all got one Piers yeah
okay you could come
and he gets there and and he ends up
being uh like the main character he fig
he doesn't want to believe that it's a
that it's a vampire yeah he's a science
guy yeah but it turns out that it is a
vampire and they did some really cool
[__]
with the end of this story
um it's okay I think if I jump ahead a
little bit
he he finally does make it to England
he's one of the few survivors I think
he's the only Survivor any yes yeah he's
the only Survivor and he makes the ship
makes it back and he makes it back but
he wasn't on the ship
he um
he got into it digging
and uh he abandoned [__] but he made it
and when he went to uh he went into a
Tavern
and Dracula found him there
[__] with him touched the back of his
head and he saw that
is man that's [__] that's Dracula
I'd know him anyway voiceover saying
that he's that this is the beginning of
his story and how he's going to commit
his life to finding this thing to
catching this thing
and he's back in England now you know
and they had set it up earlier in the
story that he had graduated from
Cambridge
so man I'm kind of seeing that possibly
what they're going to do is if they if
they remake the Dracula story he'll be
in it and he will know
to get in contact with Professor Van
Helsing because I bet you one of his
[__]
his second University professors was
found Helsing how much you want to bet I
mean if they had yeah if they're smart
that's what they would do he would go
there's this guy I know Professor van
helsink he'll probably know all about
this and then he'll be involved in it
you know I thought it was pretty cool
um
sometimes you know the way they're doing
it with this ESG score is they try to
force a bunch of kind of artificial
diversity in the story
but with this man it worked great it
felt very natural because the men of the
sea were from all they were an
international [__] group you know
they could be from anywhere they had
guys from all over [__] The Honky
motherland and they had guys from Africa
in there and Arabia and [__] all just
any anybody had some Chinese guys on the
ship with them
which that that fits you know sometimes
diversity doesn't work in stories
sometimes it really does but it's got to
fit like people don't think that [__]
Predator was a movie that had a lot of
diversity in it because that's the way
the American units looked in Central
America so I just like that when when
it's right the storytelling has got to
be right same thing with [__] the
thing you know that was a diverse cast
but it worked because that's that's the
way that situation would be
so in this case
I give it a thumbs up man I thought the
[__] cast it just felt real natural
they're like I really liked all the cast
in this yeah
um but I'm gonna get into and Corey
Hawkins who plays um Clemens who's the
you know Dr Clemens the main guy yeah I
he was bugging me because I was like God
damn it I know I've seen him in some
other [__] he was on The Walking Dead
okay a while back like in 2015 2016. he
also played Dr Dre in Straight Out of
Compton okay which came out a couple
when did that come out a couple years
ago he's got to be a British actor I
believe he is yeah yeah because they're
the only country that turns out good
English speaking actors this guy's he's
great at it oh [__] he carries the
whole [__] movie I just like this
because it was like an old school like
Gothic period horror film and it was but
it was very contained in the sense that
it so it had kind of like a thing like
like the thing or like alien or
something like that where it's just this
contained uh you know area where you
can't leave and then there's like a
monster picking you off one by one yeah
now I will say here's the thing like
when I first heard the pitch for this
that it's like we're gonna adapt
one chapter from Bram Stoker's Dracula
chapter 7 specifically which is called
the Captain's Log which is only a few
pages long I think it's probably four
pages
yeah but
um but I was like that's a really
intriguing idea I said now they're gonna
have to be careful because if you've
read Dracula which I have multiple times
it's like you you know where it's going
you know what I mean and then if you
call the movie The Last Voyage of the
demetery well well all the [__] are
gonna die they're all gonna get picked
up by Dracula because that was kind of
like when I was a kid before I read the
actual novel I had kind of like a comic
book novelization of it and one of my
favorite parts of that like one of my
favorite
um drawings from that comic book was
when the Demeter like crashed ashore
like in Whitby and they they all went on
the ship and they found the captain like
roped to the wheel like with the
crucifix and he was all [__] up and
dead and everything and I always think
that was so cool so that was actually
like one of my favorite parts of the
book and so I thought it would make a
great movie but what I didn't know
was that this idea this script has been
kicking around for more than 20 years
like the dude that wrote the spec script
he was friends with somebody that did
models on the Francis Ford Coppola
Dracula back in the 90s and he really
liked the little model of the Demeter
that they'd made for that movie and he's
like I'm gonna write like an adaptation
to that one chapter but kind of like
alien but like set on the Demeter he's
like that would be and it's really
faithful to the chapter actually yeah I
was saying that at the time when we were
when we were watching lives this is kind
of like alien in the thing the reason
why it's a thing is because at the
beginning part of it the crew was all
blaming each other
yeah yeah they didn't know who the tank
was
you know basically uh movie Works my
only problem with this [__] movie
is the release this should have been
this should have come out during
Halloween
yeah it is a little early that made a
lot more sense to me
maybe they didn't want to let go because
a lot of horror movies come out around
Halloween so maybe they didn't want to
like overcrowd it
but
um oh and I will say too that this
actually ended up being because because
this took so long to get made like I
said it was more than 20 years ago they
were like kicking the script around so
like a lot of different actors were
attached to it a lot of different
directors were attached to it at various
points but then like when it finally got
made
this was actually directed by Andre
alvordal which I think is how you
pronounce his name the Norwegian guy
he's the same guy that did troll Hunter
amazing yeah good movie uh autopsy of
Jane Doe amazing that's a great [__]
movie and scary stories to tell in the
dark which wasn't amazing but was still
pretty [__] good so this is his new
one and I was just like oh yeah that guy
but um but yeah so like I said I think
the only I think they did a good job
working around the problem of if you've
read Dracula one you know it's Dracula I
mean you know what I mean it's like you
know all the vampire lore
um so it was kind of a ballsy move to go
back to the classic [__] you know what I
mean because everybody knows that stuff
everybody knows the vampire tropes and
stuff like that so it almost seemed like
an old school like like a hammer movie
or like an old Universal movie I thought
the quality was there the acting was
there casting was there story was there
score was there yeah I really like the
score creature design I was iffy about
when I saw it when I saw the the trailer
for it I was like okay they're gonna go
for a winged nosferock to type
and the CG didn't look that good to me
in the trailer but when you see it in
the movie it works it looks good and it
doesn't
let's just say that it seems to be it
seems to morph in shape it's like it's
uh it doesn't always look like that
yeah it's getting more humanoid as it
goes he kind of like well because
sometimes you can't really see that he
has bat wings yeah sometimes he just
looks like a golemy kind of yeah
creature like at the beginning I don't
know if he had those when by the time he
got to England though remember he's
running around in the bar to hit a damn
suit on
he could pass as a human yeah he was
still kind of fugly looking yeah there
was something wrong with him but you
know he looked
he looked like uh Max Shrek kind of
yeah they did go they did go way more
like the um yeah the Salem's Lot route
he looked a lot like uh Mr Barlow I
thought yeah
kind of rat like or like nosferatio yeah
but I'm glad that they kind of did that
because like I said we don't need
another Dracula adaptation where he
looks all swab and [__] that's not true
to the story right it's like I kind of
wanted one where he'd still look like a
monster because well I thought the
implication was and I thought the
implication was there in the book too
that it's like he got more humanly
looking like the more people he munched
on right right so it's like before he
kind of looked all [__] up they added
a couple of elements
and what uh one of the main elements I
liked is that when he when they sent him
from Romania
to do this Voyage you know when his uh
when his Rome I guess they were Roma
they were carrying him their eyes his
guards yeah and um they were like his
loyal [__] guards
and uh he was in his box
and it's a special box so he can get in
and out of it's got his Earth in it
worms and [__] but there were other
boxes just how he likes it one of the
other boxes had a sacrifice in it had a
young girl in it
it's it's pretty good it's a pretty good
idea because you would think he'd want
to bring some food with him yeah you got
to pack his lunch yeah that's what I
said yeah well it's like and not that
I'm pretty sure like it's been a while
since I've read Dracula but I'm 99 sure
that that's not in the book no but then
I was thinking to myself oh that's
actually a really good idea because
um one you'd think like the village that
that he came from like they knew about
that [__] right and they were just like
here just he's going away so here take a
take a lunch with you so they sacrificed
this girl they packed her and so he had
been like feeding on her but not killing
her yeah and so when they find her
and the cargo hold like there's some
rough seas and like it falls and she
falls out and [__] like that and so
they're just like they just think she's
a stowaway and so the doctor like starts
giving her all these transfusions and
stuff like that so they kind of save her
but then she's there to give them like
kind of exposition so her and so her and
the doctor kind of play off each other
because she's like look this is like a
[__] vampire pretty much
um I don't think they ever use that word
really do they did they ever say vampire
no
oh maybe they did maybe they did I don't
think so but I don't think that I don't
think
because the Romanian girl could speak
English
and she told the crew at her Village had
an agreement
yeah
and that
to protect him and to keep from a
certain certain amount of people had to
be sacrificed yeah and they were just
like yeah and he would protect with it
yeah he would protect them if if they
protected him so they were kind of like
they had an alliance with him
and she never calls him a vampire
just said he was a beast and uh and he
says he's a monster but don't think that
he's
an animal he's he's intelligent yeah you
know
um
he said he's very intelligent but I
don't think she ever calls him a vampire
I mean maybe she did but I can't
remember I mean I'm I'm wondering if
they used that word I think maybe they
did she just I think but I don't know if
she did that he feeds on the blood of
the living
yeah he sleeps during the day yeah and
he can't come out during the day
so I like the fact that she was on there
so like I said she was there to kind of
give them some information because she
was from the village like she knew about
it and also the fact that the doctor
saved her meant that the vampire had to
get sustenance elsewhere so that's when
he started picking the crew off one by
one because he did actually need the
crew to sail him to England
um and she says at one point that uh
that he was rationing the crew because
he still needed them yeah so he was just
kind of like picking up he was like
picking off like the most useless one
first I guess or the ones that weren't
like that weren't as important as as
important for the as he got closer and
closer right right because he's like
well once I get to like a certain point
like you know then I can just start
eating all of them because that's what
he does I like the movie uh it was an
intelligent movie
it had a very classical feel to it
it felt like an older movie but like a
good older movie you know it wasn't kind
of like stereotypical
shake and big garbage you see nowadays
it was it felt very classy I liked it I
mean it did have jump scares um and it
did have it's rated R I think so it does
have some gore it's not like over the
top Gore but it does have a lot of
violence and I will note
um that I really liked and this might be
a [__] up thing to say but I really
liked that they um
went there in regards to the kid oh yeah
no because it's fair yeah and and they
not only did that you can tell this
wasn't an American director I'm gonna
say
um because they not only did that I mean
you pretty much know like going in it's
like every every one of these [__] is
gonna die because you know I read the
book I know what happened
so there's a kid on there and I'm like
I'll be really mad if they spare that
kid if you know it's obviously you don't
want kids dying in real life but in
movies usually they're not ballsy enough
he's the cabin boy but well he's the
grandson of the captain yeah too and
he's like he's an adorable kid and he's
like adorable and I'm like they better
kill that kid
um eight maybe nine ten yeah something
like that I was thinking maybe ten yeah
but yeah something like that
um but they killed the dog too which you
know but I think the dog is actually the
first one to go and then like all the
livestock but it's like so they not only
kill the kid they also like kill the kid
in a really horrible way it's really
horrible and I was just kind of like I
was I was actually pleasantly surprised
that like I said I know it's a weird
thing to say but it's like a lot of
movies won't do that you know what I
mean they're always just kind of like oh
you can't do that like everyone will get
upset I'm trying to horrify you yeah so
I was just kind of like damn yeah
they went there
set the kids of the audience I was like
holy [__] I'm supposed to be the kids it
is
that was effective to me when I was a
little kid and I [__] was when I was
this is back in the 70s I was I guess I
was about 10 8 9 10. I saw the prophecy
where that boy was [__] bouncing up
and down trying to hop away from the
mutant bear inside the [__] sleeping
bag boom and it passed him like that he
hits a tree and it just explodes in a
bunch of [__] feathers I still love
that scene man I used to cap of Sequoia
with a forest all the time they just run
into my head every time I was camping I
was like that Bear's gonna come get me
but big old [__] prophecy Bear yeah
yeah they're mutant Bear Creek which is
good you know it's good for you to be
afraid that's that is like such a
giftable scene from that movie because
it's like it's like it's horrific and
yet hilarious at the same time it's
great and it doesn't help that like the
kids
um that the sleeping bag is like yellow
so it kind of looks like a little banana
like hopping around yeah you can't get
out of it she's just starting and he's
just like it's just like inherently
ridiculous and then the Bears goes whack
in it
man it just explodes
it's so awesome yeah I can watch that
over and over
it's just that's one of the funniest
things I've ever seen yeah
that and [__] uh Michael Kane's hand
getting [__] cut off in the [__]
oh that [__] me up in the hand
anything that I didn't put my hand
outside the damn car yeah to this day if
I put my hand outside the car would I go
I think about that yeah yeah I'm the
same way anything that had any movies
when I was a kid that had like
decapitation mostly decapitation but
anything where a limb got cut off yeah
that really stressed me out and it was
like so I would think about that like
all the time
but yeah so
um like I said it I seem I I seem to see
that this is getting mixed reviews like
some like Rolling Stones seem to really
like it
um like another like Stephen King seemed
to really dig it Guillermo del Toro came
out it was because that's kind of his
Jam he loves that Gothic horror thing
and um so they like all seem to like it
but a lot of the other reviews were kind
of like meh you know what I mean it's
about like half a bad taste well yeah I
just kind of feel like
it's
um it's not like a modern horror movie
for sure it does have elements of modern
horror movies but I feel like it's more
like I don't want to go lean too hard
into saying it's like a hammer film but
it is like it's more stately yeah hey
it's a classy like that and it's like
and it's kind of classier yeah somebody
compared it to um what is that which is
not a horror movie but Master and
Commander with uh Russell Crowe and all
that
um which I guess it's kind of like that
but it's like a Gothic monstery version
of that now I hope they make the sequel
man I bet they won't because I don't
think it's making enough money but see
that would be cool it and it just seems
like Universal I mean they've been
trying we talked about this before
they've been trying to get this Dark
Universe thing off the ground and now
it's just kind of like scatter shot
everywhere yeah where it's kind of like
that now they're kind of taking the
ideas that they initially had for the
[__] and then they're just being like
whatever just make like one-off movies
like I said they made like the Invisible
Man which was like a modernization of
them I really liked that I thought that
was great
some of the other stuff like not so good
or it's like they're trying to like make
a you know uh an expanded universe and
they just can't seem to
get it together so part of the problem
is the other Hollywood Studios just
pissing in the well constantly they're
constantly making bad reboots and
[__] garbage and so the the consumer
the consumer [__]
confidence isn't there in these things
you know and um
Universal's got a bad habit of [__]
not finishing what they begin you know
they're like like like Jeremy said they
tried to reboot the universal monsters
but they can't stick to a plan or any
kind of overarching theme or anything
you know yeah you got to play on that
[__] ahead of time if you're gonna have
something that complicated it's like
writing a novel you're gonna have to
have all of this [__] and to do that you
got to have a bunch of people on board
and you got to be able to you know have
decent writing and
good actors and somebody who can [__]
control all these [__] directors and
that's just not gonna happen with these
Knuckleheads that are in the end well
and in the thing about it though is that
writing a novel is a very different
thing that's a very solitary Pursuit
generally whereas movie making is a big
team effort and it's like sometimes like
look at this movie this movie took like
more than 20 years to get off the ground
from like when the first draft of the
script was written and it just was
passed from director to director and
like different actors were attached and
then it's like you know in some like
Studio heads are like ah we don't want
to do that we have this own project so
it's like you never know and I think
that's kind of a little bit too why they
have such a hard time with these
expanded universe things because it's
just kind of like well yeah there's too
many people involved and it's like you
never know if you know the the you know
president of the company is going to
change out and it's like we're gonna
push this back and we don't want to do
that now and like everybody has their
own ideas for it and it's like there's
too many cooks in the pot so it's kind
of hard to get like a cohesive vision
you know what I mean I think so I think
if you want to do like a big cohesive
Vision like that I mean just write a
novel or a series of graphic novels or
something like that which is just like
one author if I were gonna see some
movies this week
I need to see the Meg or this one uh I
equally recommend either one of them and
they're they're totally different yeah
completely different movies I mean for
different reasons one big dumb action
movie with cool
accurate which we're going to get that
video reinstated
supposedly supposedly
um I I submitted like a little legal
um what do they call it a dispute thing
yeah and YouTube said well we've
forwarded all of your information to
them and it's like if we don't hear from
them back in 10 days and basically they
have to have enough evidence to sue you
for copyright infringement and if they
don't we'll put it back up they don't
have enough information of course they
don't no because we didn't do anything
they just didn't want they just trying
to they're just trying to jump on all
reviews I think that's what it is of the
Meg Tammy said well Stephen King and you
guys like it I'm sold yeah and Guillermo
del Toro yeah like I said if you like
old school gothic stuff if you like
Guillermo del Toro stuff if you like
Hammer movies if you like stuff like
that then you'll probably really dig it
it does have like some Modern touches to
it especially like in the monster design
and even though I've heard I don't know
how much of that was CGI I know some of
it was CGI but that was actually a guy
in a suit yeah the guy's name is um
Javier botet
Otay something like that and he's kind
of known for playing like all of these
creature kind of rolls like he's got
like an acrobat kind of dude
um so but I thought the monster looked
really cool like I said I'm glad that
they kind of went back to the old school
and I I liked the uh the likes of the
lead in it the doctor I liked him a lot
too he's real sympathetic he's uh they
think he's I guess evidently they
thought he was uh not good enough for uh
he said he couldn't get a practice
anywhere because they didn't want to
hire a black doctor so he goes to see
and when he when he tries to get on get
on a ship they look at him like now
you're too educated you're too soft yeah
we need working men you know so he's
like Caught In Between Worlds
and uh he's he has some good like little
monologues in in in in the thing in in
the in the story where he's questioning
why the way the world is why is the
world the way it is how do things
actually work he's got a he said he's a
real questioning mod and he uh he
doesn't buy into this Supernatural
[__] you know but then he sees it
for himself you know
which gives him motivation see in the
end he says I'm gonna hunt this thing
down if you know that's the last thing I
do yeah I gotta figure this [__] out
right in my mind the way they set it up
he he'd go back to the university he
came from he came from Cambridge and
he'd be looking for Dr Van Helsing
probably and ask him do you know
anything about this because he's
supposed to be an apple scientist yeah
so because like oh yeah I think I know
what you're talking about you're talking
about the [__] you appear the vampire
yeah
they're Nosferatu yeah I really did like
that they set up his character as I and
I liked too because they don't
I I have a problem sometimes with the
way that movies set up like like
skeptical or scientifically Mighty
characters a lot of times they make them
really unsympathetic or really cold or
really like this is the person whose
mind is going to be changed by all the
Paranormal Shenanigans so I like that
they set him up as very scientific
minded very skeptical like not believing
in the Paranormal stuff but he was still
like really sympathetic he wasn't a dick
about it he wasn't like lording it over
the other people like superstitious
peasants and all this other kind of
stuff and once enough evidence had
mounted he's like oh well I guess that's
what it is so now we have to like figure
out what we're gonna do you know what I
mean the kind of It kind of uh I think
he kind of from what I remember I was
under the impression that he he figured
that a vampire was just something that
had a natural explanation too yeah you
know which I guess technically some kind
of a monster because I got the
impression too they didn't really lean
into this but there was a couple of
scenes that I thought like suggested it
I thought
that
um the stuff about like vampires being
afraid of the Cross and stuff like that
they didn't really there was a couple of
scenes where there was like somebody
very obviously had like a crucifix or
something like that and it didn't help
them yeah so I but they didn't mention
it I don't even think they mentioned oh
vampires being afraid of crosses or
anything like that but a couple of
characters did have you know crosses
were like you know on necklaces and
things like that and it didn't help them
like the vampire killed them anyway so I
think they were trying to imply
maybe that this was I don't think they
were trying to imply that it wasn't a
supernatural creature but this just
maybe some of the [__] that
um that is in the vampire lore like
doesn't yeah work out in this one you're
in a related movie to this
blood vessel it's similar
a vampire-like creature at sea
that's taking place in World War II
I would recommend that one also if you
if you see this one like it or before
you see this one you can see they're
streaming blood vessel
blood vessel was a trip because it's not
really a vampire it's a it's something
above a vampire it's called a stragoy
which is what the vampire is kind of
based on
and it was a rat like
untead kind of creature that could have
children
with the living and the undead and could
impregnate dead bodies it could do all
kinds of weird ass [__] and it was a
sorcerer
it was bad [__] and and if as
I'm reading through the rules the the if
they're Romanian I believe
as I'm reading through the rules that
we're lined out on just on Wikipedia
what a struggle I could do
seemingly astragoy could cause could
create a vampire
yeah I thought they said yeah I could do
that so you know in the in the old
stories you know of Dracula
either doesn't know how he became a a a
vampire or uh he somehow turned it
because of his sin he was made into a
vampire or he can't remember like in in
that last shadow of the vampire he
couldn't remember so long
in the actual traditional lore from
Romania Australia could make a vampire I
guess my cross-breeding with a living
person
that would make a vampire yeah
we're gonna get all into that because
our our main show on Wednesday night is
all about vampire and werewolf lore okay
that finally won the poll I didn't want
to do that show for her really well yeah
so we're finally getting good so we're
doing like a whole vampire week but yeah
if you haven't seen blood vessel I think
it might be for free on 2B
it's a I think we watched it on shutter
but it might be like blood vessel yeah
that's a good primer for this movie so
if you want to see something else on
because I know that weirdly enough even
though this movie seems like it's not
making a huge amount of money
for whatever reason
um whoever makes memes is like really
into the idea of this so there are so
many like Draculas on a boat memes that
it's like not even funny like some of
them are actually pretty hilarious but
um but yeah it's kind of going all
around social media like that Dracula's
on a boat yeah um but which is kind of
funny but but like I said this is a very
very serious yeah I don't give a [__]
they they took great care to make this
as period accurate as possible as
accurate to the book as possible they
added some [__] obviously the English is
the English is period English yeah it's
archaican well it's archaic Modern
English
and the technology
a lot of the artifacts that they're
showing yeah from the sea that that's
that was all period
can I just say I love the cinematography
in this too yeah it's just gorgeous
I mean it was it's very dark obviously
because a lot of it's like dark and
stormy and everything like that and the
boat yeah the boat the Shipwreck and
everything you can see it's CG but it
looks good
yeah I thought it looked really cool so
good yeah
um but so I don't give a [__] that has
mixed reviews it's a great movie
what they say they got bad taste I mean
when we were watching it and there was
like a bunch of other people in the
theater too like I said we went like on
Saturday afternoon
and um I don't know everybody seemed to
dig it they were like really quiet and
like watching the whole thing and then
we're like 20 minutes into it and I went
to jail and says this is [__] epic
yeah
I mean it's just yeah it looked great
like I said it's just a very very
classic classy
uh kind of thing uh Maki Max says
knowing the AMC theater it might be 20
bucks uh we usually go
um AMC if you go before three o'clock
they usually give you 30 off so we saw
this movie for seven dollars each yeah
we need to go ahead 6.99 you know how to
get our [__] stubs again
we probably should now that we have that
theater there once you put in your
notice yeah
so I guess once you start working from
yeah because then we can go see movies
like now I don't have any [__] time
to go see movies except we can go see
one on the weekend and even then I don't
have time to do that sometimes because
sometimes I got other [__] to do yeah
Oracle says I think it's amazing that
it's taken this long to make a story
about the Demeter that's what I said and
like I said the guy wrote the script
like 20 something years ago and it took
this long to get the [__] [__]
written you know what I mean like he was
thinking about it like back when Francis
Ford Coppola's one came out like back in
the 90s and Oracle said it's such a
great Slow Burn mystery in the original
novel yeah it was one of my favorite
it's almost like
you know if you've never read Dracula I
think most people have read it but
if you've never read Dracula's
epistolary meaning you know it's uh it's
all letters and newspaper articles and
people's journals and [__] like that so
it's not like regular Pros
so this whole chapter which is just like
the Captain's Log describing all this
crazy [__] that was happening on the
ship on the way over
um that was always one of my favorite
parts of the book and it's almost like a
little self-contained Horror Story on
its own yeah so that's why I was so
intrigued that finally somebody thought
to because nobody really in Oracle just
said these days they they just want to
rush and get Dracula to England and
that's the thing like um some
adaptations of Dracula
that I've seen like some movie
adaptations they don't even [__]
bother with the first the whole like
first third of the novel with Jonathan
Harker in Transylvania and like the
vampire brides and all that other kind
of [__] they just kind of started with
him like showing up in England yeah so I
think the Frank langella one from the
70s is like that Dracula Spanish Dracula
had that more of that than the American
Dracula remember yeah
and that was it they had the brides and
everything
I really always really liked that like
once I liked I like the whole book it's
a great book but it's like once Dracula
gets to England it's I don't know like
it lost a little bit of magic for me I
think like my favorite parts of the book
are like the beginning where Jonathan
Harker is in the castle and like he sees
[__] Dracula climbing backwards like
down the wall and [__] like that I love
that [__] yeah there's a bunch of weird
[__] that's supposed to happen just in
Castle Dracula that's supposed to trip
you the [__] out that you were in
Romania Transylvania
seeing all this stuff and this evil dude
in this Castle I kind of wish and this
is true of like a lot of horror media
that I always that I really really like
I always kind of wish that I could go
back in time just temporarily so you
could read it or have your brain wiped
or something like that so you could read
it for the first time without knowing
that it was a vampire you know what I
mean like going back to the time because
I guess people back then that would have
read it there wasn't a lot of vampire
literature out at that point yes there
had been
um Carmella that came out before
Dracula
um Varney the vampire I think came out
and uh the vampire by John polidori that
had come out before
Hammer Carmelo's [__] hot movie
adaptations of carmilla not all of them
are great but yeah well that's kind of
your classic and like I said I think a
lot of people don't know but carmilla
came out before Dracula yeah and
Sheridan love I knew was
um Irish as well it was kind of based on
Countess bathroom
slightly yeah slightly yeah I'm pretty
sure that's what and and I think that
that that a lot of the movie adaptations
they made of it made that connection
pretty explicit yeah that it's like they
went into that you know basing it on her
but it's just kind of like how you know
Dracula everybody said it was based on
like you know Vlad tepesh or whatever
which he's not exactly but Bram Stoker
did use some of the backstory like to
inform the character I guess but the
thing about Bram Stoker was that he
researched pretty much every aspect of
vampire lore and put it all in there you
know what I mean because they're like I
said it was it's not like now when you
know there's [__] 40 bajillion
vampire movies and books and everything
like that like back then there wasn't it
wasn't really that common a monster like
to write about
you know evidently in Eastern Europe
they didn't really have vampires stories
it was it was the struggle like I was
telling you about there was a lot more
of that
seems to be that
vampire the vampire concept
is a Western European telling of the of
the you Pierre or no excuse me of this
of this drug away
um
evidently Romania didn't really have
that not not with the lore as given yeah
and it's fascinating because and like I
said we'll get more into this on
Wednesday night show because we're doing
a whole vampire werewolf lore show but
the thing about it is that a lot of
people what a lot of people now consider
the vampire rules are either from
Dracula yeah or from like you know what
I mean they're not actually from movies
from the actual folklore because the
folklore is a lot of times some of it's
the same but um a lot of it is actually
like not anything you would recognize
yeah a lot of it's like struggle stuff
or something to be closer more closely
associated with maybe like
zombies
people that come up out of the grave at
night then they go back in the grave
but they are kind of crazy they're
they're dumb yeah
they're not these Debonair flying
[__] that can turn into damn
bags
more like just a filthy [__] zombie
yeah I kind of feel like they were more
akin to a ghoul ever yeah they're just
coming up and like sucking the blood of
their relatives and whatnot
and they're all like grossing which you
could say you could say what was her
name Mina was like that no what was the
the redhead Lucy Lucy was like that kind
of she just came out at night drank
babies
and she wasn't didn't seem like the
blooper lady yeah she didn't really seem
like she was too with it you know
yeah they did kind of make her more with
it in the Francis Ford Coppola movie but
yeah yeah I thought that was and that
was another creepy part of the book too
where she was like coming out the grave
and like yeah carrying like little
babies
taking this back to snack on rules kind
of would cover everything because the
story God can make certain things and
make servants and
do my control on humans and
crossbreed with a dead body and what
comes out is like a ghoul you know so
they
it's crazy [__] you're born you're so
the child is born
Undead and dead
like a half Undead and the other half is
dead
just weird rules you know what I mean so
what's that well that's like a zombie
it rots you know but it's a blocking
yeah that kind of [__] all those
monsters have like a lot of crossover I
feel like yeah
Oracle says Lucy wasn't all that with it
when she was alive yeah
she was just hot that's true what a job
that was her whole job I'm so hot I have
three boyfriends I just can't decide I
just run around in this damn see-through
white gown I love on these [__] boobs
man my rack is epic yeah
I did I did love uh Lucy in the uh
Francis Ford Coppola oh yeah I loved all
the outfits in there yeah they were good
as a vampire too look she did yeah I
love that [__] yeah that big rough
[__] guy that was [__] awesome I
love that this I think the costume
designer might have got an Oscar
nomination I don't know if they won or
not but
um
yeah Oracle says I mean she's sweet but
not the sharpest steak in the drawer
awesome
thing I wondered speaking of like
vampire adaptations how come some
adaptations of Dracula some movie
adaptations I'm talking about how come
some of them switch Lucy and Mina I
don't know it didn't make any sense
because I know that the John badham one
from 1979 it it does that and like the
first time I said I was like wait what
it's like that's not right
um casting problems I don't know but
then like but then I saw another version
I can't remember which one it was but I
saw another adaptation of Dracula from
like maybe earlier
or maybe a little bit later I can't
remember and they did it too and I'm
like what
do y'all just not know how to read or
like the names because there's
absolutely no reason to switch those two
characters absolutely no reason at all
and I will note that the 1979 one not
only did it switch Lucy Amina but it
also made Mina wait a minute it also
made Lucy Van helsing's daughter right
or Mina van helsing's daughter
it made them like all related maybe they
were doing that so you couldn't preempt
the story
she wouldn't know what was going to
happen
Maybe
but I don't know actresses fighting over
roles maybe it looks like it didn't make
any sense to me because it's like it
didn't really switch their characters
just their names it just switched their
names yeah which I thought was kind of
bizarre
and I was like and I can't and and had
that movie been the only one to do it
it's like that would be mysterious but
I'd just be like okay whatever but then
I found out there was a couple other
ones that did that too and I'm just like
why that does not make any sense I had a
different preference for the sounds of
the names maybe yeah Oracle said Mina
was Van helsing's daughter in the 70s
when yeah that's what I thought and
didn't they make like Lucy was related
to somebody too wasn't she Dr Seward's
daughter or Dr Stewart's or something I
remember it's been a while since I've
seen it but in a couple years but I'm
pretty sure they made Lucy related to
somebody too and I think it was Dr
Stewart but I can't remember so they
made everybody related maybe they
thought that that would be more
um impactful from a character point of
view because it's like you know in the
book like Mina and Dr Ben Van Helsing
are obviously not related you know
they're just like random strangers that
become friends later on instead of like
well maybe it'll give it more like
character heft like to make them related
so it's like a bigger deal like I get
that but I don't know
yeah oral said the why is that studio
suits our idgets
yeah I'm sure that's probably the only
reason but I just I always wondered why
that was that one it's like I've never
really seen a
a definitive answer like an explanation
for why you would do that
if you're just gonna make
if you're trying to make an annotation
you know what I mean I don't know it's
just weird to me it's just something
that has always kind of fascinated me
ever since I saw that movie and I was
just like why are the characters all
switched around I don't understand but
yeah
um all right so I guess we've been going
almost an hour so I guess we can go but
uh but yeah so like I said this movie
seems to be kind of taken so if you if
it sounds cool to you then please go see
it because I really really liked it a
lot I thought it was great and yeah and
like I said if you like like real
classic like horror like you should
really like watch it
because it's really good and uh yeah so
as I mentioned if you want more vampire
action we're going to be talking about
that on the main show on Wednesday night
because we're gonna do vampire and
werewolf lore so that should be a fun
one somebody already sent me a message
today like on the poll winning thing and
said we need to dress up for that
I don't know if I'll have time because
like I said I'll only have like an hour
when I get home from work but I don't
know maybe I'll try and do some vampire
[__] we'll see we'll see what happens
but yeah so uh hopefully you guys can
join us on Wednesday night for that show
and we will see you guys then good night